[Music]
on this Wednesday night the Big Smoke
you can smell it you can feel it air
quality deteriorates from millions in
Canada and the US how long will it last
plus concerns for both physical and
mental health
Russia blamed for a ruthless attack
missiles strike a crowded restaurant in
Ukraine
the victims and the mounting pressure on
NATO to admit Ukraine the dubious way
the Kremlin is accused of tracking down
dissidents abroad
Global News investigates
and it's the 70 million dollar question
the world's biggest scavenger hunt is
going on right now well a lotto winners
step forward Before Time Runs Out
global national with Donna Friesen
reporting Tonight Eric Sorensen good
evening and thanks for joining us two of
Nature's great forces wildfires and wind
are plunging millions of Canadians and
Americans into hazardous air quality
once more the fires are burning in
Northern Ontario and Quebec and with
winds blowing from the North Americans
in Chicago and across the Midwest and
the huge population in Southern Ontario
are affected as of this morning Windsor
and Southwestern Ontario were blanketed
in Smoky Air 10 plus in Windsor very
high risk moderate in Toronto just one
in Ottawa on the Ontario air quality
index by late afternoon the numbers had
climbed in Hamilton and Toronto to high
risk and by this evening many cities
across Southern Ontario are expected to
be very high risk that Thick Smoke
making it very hard to see the skyline
of Canada's biggest city today but by no
means was Toronto alone visibility was
all but gone and major cities across the
midwestern U.S with more than 80 million
people placed under some kind of air
quality warning across several States
Jackson prosco has tonight's top story
[Music]
this is an unwanted sight and smell even
in a city nicknamed The Big Smoke
as soon as I stepped out of the door you
can smell it I'm not experiencing any
difficulty but I could see how people
would a thick blanket of wildfire smoke
descended over the most populated part
of the country choking out the Sun and
raising serious concerns for anyone
spending time Outdoors people are
wanting to get out but unfortunately
this is deterring a lot of people from
enjoying their time outside
the plume extends deep into the U.S
cities like Chicago got an unhealthy
dose of bad air while New York braced
for another hazy onslaught
it is unsafe to be outdoors use a mask
and pay attention to the alerts for this
to happen once in a season would be
remarkable that it keeps happening is
worrisome and the summer Fire season is
only just beginning
the likelihood of forest fires becoming
a bigger concern in coming decades is
something that is consistent with
climate change there are physical health
concerns from inhaling fine particulate
matter researchers are also increasingly
probing the psychological impact of
repeated weather events like fires that
can feel apocalyptic we see links
between uh just breathing these
particles and more likely depression
symptoms in people but then there's just
the this feeling of um of sort of dread
we know that there's a whole sort of
growing concern about climate anxiety
the worry is things will only get worse
as once rare events become the norm
obscuring the sunny days of summer in
the Clouds of a changing climate
Jackson crosco Global News Washington
so how long is it going to last and how
bad will it get let's bring in Global
News meteorologist Anthony Farnell for
more Anthony what can we expect heading
into this Canada Day long weekend
Eric that's an excellent question so
many Canadians wanting to get Outdoors
this weekend and if it's anything like
today with that horrible air quality in
Southern Ontario it just wouldn't be
possible there is some good news the
wind flow is changing today a Northerly
Breeze coming from Quebec right through
southern Ontario and you can see that
smoke here on our satellite imagery
smoke versus clouds further to the east
it's all because of this low pressure
system the flow around it
counterclockwise and what it's doing
it's funneling that smoke in such high
concentrations that it's affecting air
quality at the same time Northern Quebec
didn't get a lot of rain and these are
new fires and new smoke that's going to
enter the weather pattern so there comes
a time where it doesn't really matter
which direction the wind is flowing over
the next couple of days smoke is going
to be a factor but it does start to
dissipate over time and that is some
good good news heading into the long
weekend out west the heat is building 30
degree highs across Northern Alberta
into the Northwest Territories and that
is going to increase the fire risk in
that part of the country as well Eric
Global News meteorologist Anthony
Farnell thank you
[Applause]
those record-breaking wildfires and air
quality warnings prompted demonstrations
across the country today protesters
gathered in front of MP's offices on a
national day of action they're calling
on Ottawa to stop supporting the fossil
fuel industry and enact transition to
renewable energy more than 30 events
were held across the country
the U.S Coast Guard says debris and
presumed human remains from the Titan
submersible have now been recovered from
the ocean floor 10 days after the vessel
was first reported missing the parts
included what appeared to be the hull
tail and nose cone they were unloaded
from the Canadian ship Horizon Arctic at
the Coast Guard pier in St John's
Newfoundland the Titan imploded in the
North Atlantic during a dive to the
Titanic wreckage all five people on
board were killed including the T the
CEO of the company that built the
submersible the Transportation safety
board and the U.S Coast Guard have both
launched investigations
the federal government has launched a
new process to help fast-track
applications for permanent residency and
improve efforts to recruit qualified
health care workers who are in high
demand we know that over the course of
the fast past few years our health care
sector has been hit extremely hard we
also know that it is not just a labor
shortage today that we need to be
concerned with it's a scale shortage for
the Next Generation
starting today the government is sending
500 Express entry invitations to
candidates looking to apply for
permanent residency they include doctors
nurses dentists and pharmacists the next
round opens July 5th for experts in
science technology engineering and math
three children are among the victims of
a deadly Russian missile strike on a
crowded restaurant in eastern Ukraine
the attack killed 11 people yesterday
including 14 year old twin girls the
Kremlin insists it does not Target
civilians but its Relentless assault has
Ukraine ramping up its pressure to join
NATO as soon as possible Redmond Shannon
reports and a warning some of the images
are disturbing
eight-month-old baby among the injured
in a Russian missile attack that hit a
chromatorsk pizza restaurant about 20
kilometers inside the Ukrainian side of
the front line not not your head if you
can hear us more than 50 people were
injured among the dead Anna and Yulia
axonchenko twins who would have turned
15 in September
Ukraine's President Vladimir zielinski
said it's another example of Russian
Terror
the Kremlin said its airstrike hit a
temporary Ukrainian Army command post
Russian military
not attacking civilian infrastructure
Kiev zelenski welcomed two of his
closest allies
Poland's Andrei Duda and lithuania's
Gitana noseda both want Ukraine admitted
to Nato as soon as possible a view
shared by many NATO countries bordering
Russia we need to send a strong message
of Hope to the Ukrainian soldiers in the
trenches that with NATO membership on
the horizon they are fighting their last
war with Russia NATO Chief Jens
doltenberg a little more measured ahead
of next month's NATO Summit I think it's
too early to
pre-announce the outcome of the winter
summer in Russia the Moscow times
reports that Sergey sarovkin a former
commander of Russia's Invasion has been
arrested earlier the New York Times said
U.S intelligence believed he knew in
advance about Evgeni pregozian's
attempted Mutiny there is 10 perhaps a
split within the Russian military
establishment with some commanders who
have been close to rigosian that
Rebellion cracked the foundations of
Vladimir Putin's Authority something he
aimed to repair before it might collapse
Redmond Shannon Global News London
despite Russia's war on Ukraine it
appears the Kremlin is still able to use
Interpol the international police Agency
for the past Century countries have
turned to that organization to share
information about suspected criminals
but Russia's political opponents say
it's abusing the system using Interpol
to find and arrest dissidents abroad
including those who speak out against
the war Global News spoke to one man
living in constant fear of being hunted
down Jeff simple has this exclusive
report
[Music]
called Russia's Bob Dylan
Boris grabinjikov and his band aquarium
have been rocking crowds like this one
in Toronto for five decades making his
American television debut please welcome
Boris grebenchikov
that's him with David Letterman in 1989
just months before the Berlin Wall came
down do the Russians know you're here uh
but grabinjikov's powerful voice has now
been silenced in his own country one day
after Russia invaded Ukraine gavinchikov
called the war Russia's Madness and
shame in an interview with global news
he doubled down the evil
sort of said Patriots
crying kill the ukrainians and this is
madness rabinchikov is now facing
criminal charges in Russia and up to 15
years in prison he has no plans to
return anytime soon but even outside
Russia the kremlin's political opponents
say they're not safe
[Music]
I'm in a constant state of fear says
Russian political activist Arthur
zaripov a couple of years ago zaripov's
anti-kremlin protests landed him in
prison
exactly
arrested in dramatic fashion accused of
terrorism after 18 months zaripov was
released on house arrest and managed to
escape the country he's now living in
Poland but even there he's been detained
and eventually released four times
I found out that I was on interpol's
Wanted list he says European countries
know Putin is a liar I don't understand
why they're still cooperating with
Russia through Interpol Interpol is the
world's largest International police
organization with 195 member states but
Russia is single-handedly responsible
for a whopping 38 percent of all public
Interpol red notices and critics say the
Kremlin is abusing the system to hunt
down its political opponents following
the invasion of Ukraine Canada the US
and others called for Interpol to
suspend Russia in a statement the agency
says its Constitution calls on the
organization to maintain police
cooperation and ensure communication
channels remain open nor is there any
provision in the constitution for the
suspension or exclusion of a member
country Russia should have been
suspended from Interpol long before the
invasion of Ukraine prominent Kremlin
critic Bill Browder says Russia has
tried to add him to interpol's Wanted
list eight times he was arrested in
Spain in 2018 sparking a global outcry
and it was only because I tweeted out
when I was being arrested that a whole
International Firestorm was created but
for a lot of people that wouldn't happen
[Music]
Russia's political opponents say every
time they cross a border they risk
arrest or worse but grabinshikov won't
be silenced that's the way I feel you
know I can't conceal that if you keep
silent it's still corrosive from inside
Jeff sample Global News Toronto
tempers flare in Paris
[Music]
coming up what's Behind These violent
protests against police
plus torched the mountain of illegal
drugs that went up in flames
[Music]
thank you
in Paris fiery protests erupted
overnight after a teenager was shot
fatally by police during a traffic stop
dozens of cars were burned 31 people
arrested and 25 officers were injured
witness video shows two police officers
beside the car before it pulls away and
an officer fires into the vehicle
[Applause]
the 17-year-old victim died from at
least one gunshot wound to the chest one
officer has been detained on homicide
charges the French government is calling
for calm and has tightened security
around Paris and other cities
authorities in Myanmar have torched
nearly half a billion dollars worth of
illegal drugs to Mark international
anti-drug trafficking day piles of
heroin cannabis meth MDMA and opium were
burned in a ceremony on Monday all of it
seized from different parts of the
country authorities have long struggled
to crack down on the country's illegal
drug trade a recent increase in
production is believed to be connected
to political and economic unrest since a
military coup took place two years ago
[Music]
reptile Revelation ahead the Canadian
connection between a venomous lizard and
a popular diabetes drug
[Music]
imagine this little guy beside you on a
hot day this is Rocky and he has just
secured the Guinness world record for
the longest tongue on a living dog Rocky
lives in Illinois with his owner and she
contacted Guinness when she realized her
boxer could be a contender
Rocky had to go under anesthesia to get
measured his tongue came in at just
under five and a half inches almost 14
centimeters Size Matters
another long-tongued species is
connected to a scientific breakthrough
Making Waves in the medical world a gila
monster a venomous lizard in the
southern U.S is laying the groundwork
for some promising medications and
there's a Canadian connection Global's
Catherine Ward explains
by now it's likely you've heard of
ozempic zempix being used by the Rich
and Famous the diabetes medication which
has been making headlines for weight
loss but perhaps a lesser known fact is
that ozembic has ties to Canada and well
if you can believe it a lizard yep that
lizard a gila monster which is a
venomous reptile native to the southern
U.S I did basic science I really had no
idea where this would lead in the 1980s
Canadian researcher Dr Daniel Drucker
discovered a hormone in the human gut
and it was a very powerful stimulator of
insulin secretion and very importantly
it only stimulated insulin secretion
when the glucose was elevated he and
many other scientists were trying to
figure out how to turn it into a
diabetes drug the problem was that
manufactured samples dissolve too
quickly but Drucker had heard about a
lizard down south whose Venom had a
similar hormone with more staying power
in the 1990s there were there was no
Gene Banks you couldn't look stuff up
online you actually had to clone stuff
and in order to do that we had to get
lizard dna the Royal Ontario Museum gave
that job to Bob Murphy we arranged for
the purchase of the lizard and its
shipment as Airline cargo to Toronto
Harrison I picked it up it paid off
decades later the medical community is
taking the discovery to new heights not
only is this technology being used to
make ozempic treatments for Alzheimer's
addiction and heart disease are also in
the works the reality is that this is a
very strong network of scientists
communicating and working together
proving that breakthroughs can happen
just about anywhere it's having a huge
clinical impact globally which is just
great to see as a physician Catherine
Ward Global News Toronto
Madonna is having some serious health
issues and has postponed her World Tour
the 64 year old singer developed a
serious bacterial infection which led to
several days in the ICU according to her
manager he says she's expected to make a
full recovery but all her commitments
have been postponed Madonna was set to
kick off her celebration tour in
Vancouver next month
70 million dollar Lotto mystery next
searching for the winner before the
ticket expires
[Music]
a Monumental moment tonight for a
Canadian hockey Phenom Conor Bedard all
but assured of being the first overall
pick in this year's NHL draft the North
Vancouver teen is considered a
generational Prospect with the potential
to become one of Canada's all-time
hockey greats the lucky team with the
rights to select Bedard the Chicago
Blackhawks winners of the NHL draft
lottery
and speaking of lottery winners there's
one missing today is the final day for
the owner of a 70 million dollar winning
ticket in Ontario to come forward it was
sold last year in Scarborough but who
bought it is still a mystery and time is
running out if no one comes forward it
will be the largest unclaimed prize in
Canadian Lottery history Mike jollay
reports on the search to find the winner
and what could happen to all that money
every Lotto winner gets the big check
the confetti they save for the jackpots
but over the past year the Ontario
Lottery and Gaming Corporation has been
waiting and waiting and waiting to blast
that confetti into the air because
somewhere someone has a 70 million
dollar ticket that expires tonight I
hope somebody claims this prize by 10 30
tonight because I just feel sick for
whoever has had or has got this ticket
the OLG has put the word out search your
drawers
wallets jackets
anywhere you may have left a stray
ticket bought at one of Scarborough's
400 retailers right now I think there's
the uh the world's biggest scavenger
hunt is going on right now uh with
people that buy the Lotto Max ticket in
Ontario there's plenty of dreaming going
on the OLG has received 1100 calls from
people claiming they lost the winning
ticket hey Jeff dreaming of the 70
million
share it with Mike now hey Eric you look
for your lottery ticket
you realize how impossibly long the odds
are of winning
come on hey Alan what's the lottery
dream have you ever considered that we
are living the dream and yes it's a long
shot an extreme one but there is
precedent holy mackerel
this is weird in 2012 Kathy Jones bought
toothpaste and a lotto ticket and then
promptly lost her ticket the OLG tracked
her down a year later through her
banking information and awarded her the
50 million dollar prize I feel almost as
though I I've been struck by lightning
twice will lightning strike a third time
tick tock tick tock Mike drolet Global
News Toronto
a nice global national for this
Wednesday I'm Eric Sorensen
Muslims around the world including here
in Canada are celebrating the start of
Eid al-hada one of the largest Islamic
holidays known as the Feast of sacrifice
it marks the end of the annual
pilgrimage to the holy city of Mecca and
is a time for the Muslim Community to
pray enjoy feasts and share gifts among
loved ones Jeff Semple will be here
tomorrow thanks for watching good night
[Music]
thank you